okay um
so the story so far is that 200,000
years ago we humans Homo sapiens we um
were born in
Africa and then about uh 50,000 years
ago because of climate change we started
to spread around the world okay um we
went into Europe then into Asia then we
crossed the bearing straight into
North America then South America then
Asia went to Australia okay and 50,000
years ago there's about a million of us
all around the world and the argument
that I'm making you that I made to you
in this class is that from the very
beginning we were religious okay we know
from the ice cave paintings we know
because of place like goe and kind of
Hoak that we had um a religious belief
that told us who we are and what we're
doing here and as we discussed in class
this religious belief is um animistic
meaning we believe that we all come from
One Source the mother
goddess
and we are all the children of the
mother goddess including animals
plants and because of this we are we
were a very compassionate
uh people that were egalitarian there
was no difference between men and women
that was peaceful we we were violent
there was some violence but we didn't
really fight Wars okay um and we're
artistic we celebrated the mother
goddess through paintings and through
artwork okay um and now the question
then is if we were like this for most of
human history
how is it that today we have War private
property and patriarchy where men make
all the rules and women have little
agency and power and so this week I will
explain to you how this
happened okay so in today's class we
will discuss um really the height of
this
civilization um and this is what the
anthropologist
Maria gambas called Old Europe okay so
to begin the story um I want to tell you
what what we've discovered in terms of
linguistics
so for many hundreds of
years we many people have speculated
that maybe English German greek latin
all came from the same language that's
been lost to us this is language we call
Proto
indoan um and through Decades of strous
research linguists have been able to
conclusively uh prove that all these
languages that we speak in Europe okay
all come from the same mother language
the first language but not only that but
also
Iranian um and Indian okay Hindi okay
all come from Proto
induran so the question so okay does
that make sense to you guys all
right so we know this because there are
many words that sound the very that
sound the same in many language okay so
for example father in English is father
right but in Latin it's p okay that's
where we get the the word uh paternity
okay from the father um Greek patus
persan hardar Hindi in India P okay so
the word father seems to come from just
one word in all these different
languages then you look at the word
mother okay mother mat matara M mat okay
also sounds very similar so again
for hundred of years people people have
speculated that
um there was just one language and if
you look at this map okay so for example
the English word uh for two okay the
number two you can draw a schematic that
shows you how all these languages the
word two derived just from one word da
okay so linguists have been able to
piece together this Proto
induran uh
language we've also been able to figure
out how this language spread okay so
there are two hypotheses either the
language spread from uh turkey Anatolia
or from uh Ukraine okay basically Russia
and um we know it spread all around the
world okay so basically all of Europe
and including Iran and India okay
so this is the first language of all
these language language that we speak
today in most of Asia and all of Europe
okay so any questions so
far all
right now the problem for linguist is
how do you piece together the language
okay because this language is lost to
us okay all so this language is lost to
us and so what linguage did okay and
this is a very slow process is they
basically looked at all the words that
seem to come from the same word in
different languages what they discovered
is that there's certain words that are
distinct to the first language so words
like B cow Ox Ram e Lamb pig piglet sour
milk why CDs Field Dog sheer wool
textiles uh scratch plow oxen yoke grain
sha Furrow wrestling grinding pestl
households okay what do you guys notice
about these words do you see patterns in
these
words what patterns do you see in these
words okay so what these words tell us
is the culture and lifestyle of the
Proto indo-europeans okay does that make
sense so from these words we're able to
figure out four things about the uh
Proto uh Indo Europeans the first thing
is that unlike other cultures these
people have a word for wheel in fact
there are five different words for wheel
and what this tells us what we can guess
that these people whoever they are they
invented the
wheel okay does that make sense because
have they have word for words for wheel
and other closes don't okay so they were
the first invent the wheel second is
that they have words for dairy products
okay cow milk and this is
important why do you guys know know why
why this is
important why is this strange
yes okay so they were racing livestock
okay okay what makes it strange is that
for most of human history we were
lactose intolerant meaning we did not
have the ability to drink milk so these
people not only did they invent the
wheel but they but they changed their
system biological system so that they
became lactose tolerant they now have
the capacity to drink milk okay does
that make sense so whoever these people
are are the first people to drink cow
milk okay the second characteristic
sorry the third characteristic is they
really don't have that many agricultural
terms okay so maybe they farmed but they
weren't um focused on farming okay
whereas other cultures were focused on
farming okay that's the third thing the
fourth thing is is they have words for
horse and this is important because this
tells us that they were first to
domesticate the horse meaning that they
could control the horse okay this is
important because throughout history
horses if they see a human they run away
okay because that's the best way to
survive if you see someone coming you
run away this this is what we call
excitability okay horses are cited so it
took thousands of years for these people
the Proto indo-europeans to domesticate
the horse which means they could ride
the
horse okay doesn't make sense so we
don't know who these people were but
based on their language were able to
guess four things okay so this is a
theory now what's interesting is that
archaeologists start to dig up things
and they start to discover
the linguage were right okay by sing the
language the the linguage had four
hypotheses and the AR the archaeologists
were able to provide evidence this is
true okay the most exciting thing is
that for the past 5 to 10 years advances
in genetics DNA technology we've been
able to look at the DNA of these
skeletons and we've been able to confirm
a lot of these hypotheses okay does that
make sense so what I'm what I'm telling
you is for the longest time we guess
that the Proto Indo Europeans existed
but now we have conclusive conclusive
cic evidence that they did exist and who
they were okay does that make
sense all
right
so Wheels okay so again they have five
five different words for wheels and
we're able to know from the
archaological
evidence the wheels were invented about
3500 BC okay in this area okay basically
Russia um and because wheels are part of
Proto indoeuropean then this language
whoever starts as first speak it must
have been speaking after 3500 okay does
that make
sense all
right um there aren't that many
agricultural terms in Proto Indo uh
European
okay we have a lot of words for milk
okay to milk sour milk buttermilk cheese
cow okay so whoever these people were uh
dairy products were a very important
part of their culture and their
diet um this is DNA DNA evidence that
shows
us that these people who who we call the
yaya okay these people called the yaya
um they were able to develop hormones
that allow them to be
lactose tolerant okay
um in about four four 4500 BCE very few
people could drink milk and by the time
of the yaya about a thousand years later
they could basically all drink milk and
because they could drink milk what
happens to their body can you guys know
what's the difference if you drink
milk exactly okay so we know from the
evidence that these people are taller
than everyone else in fact these people
people because they drink milk and they
eat a lot of
protein um they were on average 20 cm
taller than Farmers okay does that make
sense you guys
okay yeah go ahead
okay okay okay so the drink the milk we
drink today is very different from the
milk that they drank before you
understand the milk they drank before
came from cows that were raised in
grassland so it's all natural the milk
we drink today comes from cows that are
raised in factories and we in we inject
a lot of drugs and hormones into these
cows did you understand
uh no no no no if you drink milk a lot
uh your bones will be healthier and
you'll grow taller okay that that's just
that's just biological evidence okay
does that make sense but the milk we
drink today um we put a lot of chemicals
into the milk and the sourcing of the
milk uh is from factories okay and and
and the reason why is we want to make
the milk cheaper but it's worse for you
okay so in other words if you really
want to be healthy what you you should
do is go buy a cow and drink from that
cow okay do you understand all
right okay so so are we clear okay all
right now what's really interesting is
the domestication of the horse Okay so
again there's a gene in the horse for
accessibility okay basically the horse
is programmed to run away if it sees
danger a human being and it took us
about 3,000 years okay from 5500 BC
until 20200 BC to domesticate the horse
because it's very hard to make horses
not run away when there's danger does
that make sense so this a very long
process but they were able to accomplish
it um the further evidence for the
domestication of a horse is we've been
able to dig up skeletons okay and what
we see is the
skeletons of the yayah are different
from other skeletons and it's because
they ride horses okay that
changes the curvature of the skeleton
okay does it make sense guys okay so the
evidence is pretty overwhelming
um eventually they were able to put all
the pieces together okay they were able
to put the horse and the wheel together
and as such they create the wagon the
wagon meant they could move from place
to place and they they became what we
call nomadic pastures pastur list okay
so have you guys been to
Mongolia have you guys been to
Mongolia ex me yeah same okay but you
see the way they um the way they make a
living is they have like cows and sheep
right and they take the cows from the
sheep from place to place to eat the
grass right and they can they're able to
do that because they're able to put all
the belongings into a wagon and move
from place to place okay does that make
sense so these are the
people who were the first speakers of
Proto indur Indo European and eventually
they're able to spread their language
all around the world okay from Europe to
India to Iran okay does that make sense
guys now the question is okay we able to
confirm that these people actually
existed and we are able to
confirm that they um did spread the
language around the world now the
question the debate is how do they do so
okay and there's two sides to the
argument the first
side um the first side believes these
people were conquerors okay so think
gangas Khan and the Mongols they went
around they and they they they they they
were able to spread their language by
conquering other people okay so think
gangas Khan and the Mongols think of the
European conquest of North and South
America where the English and Spanish
and the French went to North and South
America and eradicated the local
population okay so that's the first
belief the second belief is that it was
not violent okay it was just cultural
diffusion meaning I came to your um
country or your village and I was able
to influence you and convince you that
my language is superior okay so we call
this cultural diffusion so think of
English where okay China has not been
conquered by the west but we want to
learn English because we think that
learning English will give us more life
opportunities okay does that make sense
so there's two sides of the debate
either one of conquest or one of
cultural diffusion and this debate went
on for a long time okay and for most of
the time we believed it was cultural
diffusion
but now for the past 5 to 10 years we
have overwhelming DNA evidence that it
was in fact Conquest it was a genocide
it was a violent conquest and this is
what I will show you next class okay but
in today's class what I will show you is
the Europe before the
conquest okay does that make sense okay
and then next class we will look at how
Europe was conquered and how you was
changed because of the conquest okay any
questions so
far okay so so the so so it's a great
question okay the question is what's the
difference between conquest and the
fusion okay the answer is
this if I con coner you I eradicate your
genes I kill you okay Therefore your
genes do not come into the present day
whereas if it's defusion your genes are
still around does that make
sense okay so now what I will show you
next class is sorry A lot of these genes
have been eradicated therefore it must
have been a violent
Conquest does that make
sense okay all right so
um let's now look at Europe before the
conquest and a lot of um what we know
about Europe um comes
from a very famous Anthropologist her
name is Maria gatas okay and we we'll be
spending a lot of time this today
talking about her theories but what we
know is okay remember the Ice Age ended
about 12,000 years ago okay now the
planet is warming which allows for
agriculture we also know that
agriculture started in uh Anatolia
turkey and in Egypt and in uh
Mesopotamia okay basically this region
and the region why is this place was the
first to warm up but it also had better
soil than other places okay so they
discovered farming in this region and
then about 6,500 BCE agriculture start
to
spread around the world okay to Europe
and then over to um England right does
that make sense guys okay now the
question then is what propelled this
migration from Anatolia to Europe can
you guys
guess what would what would Propel this
migration okay a good guess is war okay
but we don't have any evidence of War
around this time what's another
explanation why people wouldn't
move exactly thank you climate change
okay the weather became a lot cooler
during this time Mak it harder for
people to farm okay also they've been
farming for a long time in this area
which meant that the soul the the soil
is no longer as good as before okay so
you had these massive migrations of
families into Europe because Europe at
this time it was becoming the weather
was becoming a lot um warmer which
allowed people to start to grow
agriculture in this area okay so in
about 6,500 BCE people start from to
move from Anatolia into this area and
because they were moving they brought
with them their religion okay remember
like like the religion of goe and kind
of Hoak is one of the mother goddess
giving life to everything okay and
because of that we know that the people
in this area were mainly
egalitarian peaceful and artistic okay
does that make
sense okay um what we'll what we will
study next class is that there were two
massive migrations into Europe all
caused by climate change the first
migration um are farmers okay the second
migration are pastelist and what I will
show you next class
is the we will look at the DNA evidence
okay so if you look at the D DNA of
people today what you will see is that
um about 4500
BCE most people in Europe their genes
were mixed of farmers who came from
Anatolia as well as H gatherers who were
there originally okay does that make
sense but then um after 3,000 BC you
have this green come in okay and the
green are the Y Yaya okay the Proto
indo-europeans and so I will show show
you this next class okay but but I want
you guys to understand what happened
okay does that make sense
okay so again this is a map of the
migration okay so agriculture was
founded in about 9,000 BC in uh the near
East turkey Anatolia as well as uh
Israel Syria Jordan then it spread from
about from about 7,000 to Europe okay
and then the purple is the am people
okay who who believe were from Ukraine
in the steps they spread
around the world next class we'll
discuss who the yah were and how they
conquered the world okay but first I I
want to look at the farmers who built
Europe before the conquest of the
anayah um so again Maria gutas who is an
anthropologist originally from uh
lutherania but who worked at Harvard and
UCLA she's done Decades of
research
into Old Europe okay and her
conclusion is that old
Europe um was
conquered
by um the yayah people okay and this
this is what what we know as the Kiran
hypothesis so let me let me explain what
the Kiran hypothesis
is we know the burials
of the farmers is very different from
the burials of the yayah people the
major difference is this the people who
are farmers are buried together okay but
the people of the anayah they're buried
alone not only are they buried alone but
they're buried with
weapons and with cattle and horses so
what we can guess from this okay we
don't have evidence but we can what we
get can guess from this is is that the
farmers were people who did not have PIV
private property and who were
egalitarian okay and who were peaceful
because they didn't have any weapons and
the anayah were the complete opposite
okay these were
warriors
who um uh believed in private
property and which was male-dominated
okay doesn't make sense so this is what
what we refer to as the kirken
hypothesis and for the longest time this
is something that Maria gutes
argued and she was laughed at why was
she laugh
that why would people laugh at her she's
saying like Okay before these came to
Europe Europe was a place that was
basically governed by woman and it was
artistic and it it was peaceful it was
egalitarian why would people laugh at
her yeah they don't believe in her
why
and excuse
me yeah yeah first of all in
universities it's the men who are the
professors right it's the men who are
Scholars so there are many men who are
like there's no way woman can be in
charge they're idiots
okay why would women be in charge
they're stupid they're useless it's men
who are always in charge okay that's one
reason why they laugh at her what's
another reason why they would laugh at
her okay there are also a lot of people
who believe like people are violent
we've had Wars always okay they idea
like for like Thousand Years Europe was
peaceful can't be true because people
are violent humans are meant to go to
war against each
other Okay the third reason why people
would laugh at her is we think that we
are motivated by
money right if you don't have money then
why would you do anything does that make
sense
so Maria gbas had this radical idea that
challenge the way that men saw the world
okay for men men has men have always
been in charge there's always been Wars
and there's always been wealth and money
to motivate people to work hard okay and
that's and that's what men believe and
Mar G said no that's not true for
thousand of years from 6,500 uh BC until
about 2500 BC 4,000 years before they
were conquered Europe was ruled by woman
and because of that Europe was peaceful
egalitarian and artistic okay so this is
a radical idea
and again what I what I will show you
next class is this idea that was laughed
at for decades has has now been
confirmed by DNA evidence meaning that
this has been proven True by science
okay does that make sense okay so let's
look at what Mir but said and she's
written quite a few books these are two
of her most famous the language of the
goddess and the civilization of the
Goddess okay so her main theory is that
Europe at that time their main belief is
in the mother goddess who gives life to
everything
okay and so what she did was she went
and she dug up their uh Graves to look
at their art and she studied their
language and their cultural practice
okay does that make sense any questions
so
far okay so this is from the
civilization of the goddess and we'll
read this together okay and and so this
is her main argument about Old Europe at
that time the goddess in all her
manifestations was a symbol of the unity
of all life in nature okay so we are all
connected together animals trees humans
we're all connected together okay were
all one big family her power was in
water and stone in Tomb and cave in
animals and birds snakes and fish Hills
trees and flowers hence the holistic and
mytho perception of all the sacredness
and mystery of all there is on Earth
okay so everything in the world is
sacred because it is blessed by the
mother goddess if there's a mosquito
don't kill that mosquito because it is
has the energy of MC of the mother
goddess okay if you are walking on a if
you're walking and you see a bird a
small bird pick it up and and and heal
it okay because that comes from a mod
goddess okay does that make
sense this culture took deep Delight in
the natural wonders of this world its
people did not produce lethal weapons or
build fors in in exceptable places as
their successors did even when they were
acquainted with Metallurgy okay so in
other words they had the technology to
make weapons they had the technology to
build forts and make war but they chose
not to does that make sense okay these
people chose purposely chose not to
commit violence against other people
instead they built magnificent Tom
shrines and temples comfortable house in
moderately sized Villages and created
superb pottery and sculptures this was a
long long lasting period of remarkable
creativity and stability and age free of
strife their culture was a culture of
art it doesn't make sense they spent all
their time and energy in producing art
to celebrate the mother goddess and to
celebrate nature and to celebrate
themselves okay and this was remarkably
peaceful and stable does that make sense
guys okay any question so
far okay
what was amazing about this culture is
they invented writing okay now for the
longest time we believe that the
samarians okay which we will discuss
later on the samarians who lived in Iraq
we believe they discovered um writing
okay and we discover that writing came
about for economic purposes okay so for
example if you are in Samaria and you
need you you need to build a temple okay
what you do is you create writing so for
example example okay here's a CL I and I
say
this okay so this is writing right what
what do this it means like these two
people this family of two will get two
bushes of Wheat and two bases of bread
for their work today does that make
sense so we thought that for the longest
time people created writing because or
for economic purposes okay in order to
have an
economy but what M gutus has discovered
is no we actually created writing before
for religious purposes okay so for
example if I have a painting okay it
goes like
this okay something like this then what
I'm saying is the mother god goddess BL
blesses this
um
sculpture with her life and with the
abundance of water in nature okay does
that make sense so writing is a way to
communicate with the mother goddess is a
way to make Divine and
sacred um our art does it make sense
guys okay
so um these people are so sophisticated
they invented writing
okay now I want to go over some of the
cultural
differences between that culture and our
culture to show how Stark the difference
is okay so for example in today's
culture we think of snake we think of
poison danger right we've been taught
that snakes are dangerous but in this
culture the snake was a symbol of Life
Energy and regeneration because you know
snake can shed their skin right a most
benevolent not an evil creature okay so
that's one major difference another
major difference between our culture and
their culture is in today's world we
think that white is good black is bad
right and we can't
imagine that black is good white is bad
right but their culture that's what
exactly what they believe okay black did
not mean death or the underworld it was
the color of fertility the color of damp
caves and rich soil of the womb of the
Goddess where life begins white on the
other hand was the color of death of
bones okay does that make sense so back
then for most of of human history we
thought
that um white was bad because it
symbolized death and black was good
because it symbolized life and we can't
possibly imagine that today right okay
the last thing I want to talk about and
this is actually the most controversial
thing
is back then for most of human history
woman had power and agency okay what I
mean by that is back then a wi's body
was her body she could choose to to do
whatever she wants with her body does
that make
sense in today's world if you get
married right if a woman gets married
then we assume the woman's body belongs
to the husband only the husband can
sleep with her it doesn't make sense but
for most of of human history this was
not true
okay all
right so you look at sexual taboos today
okay why do we have sexual taboos to
shame woman into proper behavior okay so
for example
okay if a man sleeps with a thousand
woman we we think great he's a stud he's
good-looking he's Rich he's tall he's a
stud right but hey if a woman sleeps
with a thousand men she's a she's a
bad person she has no ethical um she
lacks ethics she lacks morality she's a
she has no character therefore we must
avoid her
okay why does this make any logical
sense
why is this
true guys why is this
true okay
yeah exactly we we have this okay we
have this Prejudice because men are
considered Superior to women and
therefore men want to control woman and
the best way to do that is by
controlling the woman's body okay does
that make sense okay so this is just a
cultural Prejudice there's no bi
biological evidence this is true okay
all right
so
um we we have a lot of
evidence that um
women want sexual agency okay women w't
have sex there's something wrong with
that okay so for example we look at
monkeys Reese's monkeys and females will
aggressively seek males out for sex okay
so it's the females that are
proactive you also look at Bono bonobos
monkeys okay in Bon monkeys it's
interesting because the females are in
charge the females have sex with each
other why why why why do they have sex w
w with each
other where will females have sex with
with each other what's the purpose
purpose of
that Unity right does that make sense
Unity to get along to cooperate better
okay and then they will
also have sex with uh men but they
initiate the sex okay there are some
cultures where it's the female that will
initiate the sex with the male okay all
right so um at Harvard in UCLA they
discovered okay the moment they
discovered um the plow AR
agriculture these societies have lower
levels of female participation in
politics in the laboral force okay
meaning like before before where men and
women did the same work both had the
same political power but once men uh
showed that they could contribute more
to society Men start to have more power
okay does that make sense so in other
words um differences between men and
women are not biological constructs okay
they are cultural
constructs and for most of human history
men and women were
equal okay any questions so
far okay so the idea of black and white
it's a like white is good black is bad
it's a recent construct okay it comes
with the idea of
race okay and race was invented about
200 years ago why because Europe was
going going on Conquering the world and
they needed to justify why they were
doing this and the theory is because
we're Superior people our race is better
than your race does that make sense so
race is a recent cultural construct
and um it was to justify imperialism the
conquest of other people for no reason
okay does that make sense okay so all
this is recent
okay all
right there's a really fun book called
sex at dawn by Christopher Ryan okay and
what he argues is that for most of human
history woman had sexual agency and they
had multiple uh sexual partners and one
piece of evidence is
this gorillas right they're the biggest
primates they're huge right what turns
out their penises when fully erect is
only 4 cm okay men who are a lot smaller
than um gorillas when they're wrecked
they are at least almost four times as
big as the gorilla penis is okay
so the question then
is why is this the case and one theory
is that when women have multiple sexual
partners the man with the bigger
penis will spread his Gene forward does
that make sense
guys okay and so this is a this is
evidence like for most of human history
women have had multiple sexual
partners
okay
okay so even when women had Partners
okay a husband they still had sexual
partners okay and in some societies
women have many husbands usually
Brothers together okay all right let me
ask you this question
why do they do
this right because we've been taught
this we've been taught okay we exist to
spread our
genes right you understand so if I marry
someone only if I'm sure that The
Offspring the children are
mine will I work hard to ensure that the
children are fed and raised properly and
educated okay does that make sense so
we've been taught for a long time that
we first care about our genes okay
that's why men want to have as many
wives and children as possible and woman
want to find the wealthiest
husband but before most of of human
history this was not true why
why
guys okay so it has to do with the idea
of religion okay so the first thing is
that we all come from the mother goddess
we're all equal right so it doesn't
matter if my if it doesn't matter if
it's my son or my friend's son they're
all the children of the mother goddess
and therefore I have responsibility to
protect the children okay does that make
sense so there is
no concept of
individual there's only a concept of
community okay that's the first thing
second thing
is they really didn't understand genes
okay they they didn't understand like
okay a child has 50% genes from the
mother 50% genes from the father okay
how they understood was
okay you have the woman she gives life
the the the man gives
energy okay does that make
sense therefore what if you believe this
then what if the mother gives life the
man gives
energy
what
what right right but how would you get
better
energy more men right you understand if
men are giving you energy the more men
you have sex with the more energy you
have does that make
sense so the evidence is if you look at
the people in millenia okay they believe
that provided energy and so you need you
need a lot of semen okay so what would
happen is that when a woman married a
husband what happened is the members of
the husband's family would come and have
sex with her that very night in order to
get as much energy as possible from the
family does it make sense guys
okay any questions so far I know this is
controversial
but I'm just trying to show you how our
cultural beliefs is radically different
from the cultural beliefs of people in
the
past okay does it make
sense okay so one last piece of of
evidence is
this when you don't
know
who your who's
when the when the people don't know who
the father is everyone has a
responsibility to protect the child okay
does that make sense to you guys okay so
the story is this Christian Miss
missionary he goes into a village and he
he finds people just sleeping with each
other okay there's no marriage there's
no husband and wife people are just
sleeping with each other and the priest
says to them you people are Shameless
and one of the villagers
replies you have no sense you French
people love only your own children but
we all love all the children of our
tribe okay you understand so having
multiple sexual partners is a way to
build community for everyone if you're a
small community okay maybe 15 20 people
it makes sense to make sure that
everyone loves each other and everyone
will protect all the children does that
make sense guys right so let me tell you
a story to illustrate this fact we know
that in World War II okay in World War
II
American uh Pilots
okay what they were doing for what what
they were doing is they were sleeping
with each other's
wife okay doesn't make sense the reason
why they were doing this is American
Pilots were more likely to die in war
than any other soldiers does that make
sense guys therefore you slept with the
wife of your
colleagues in order to ensure that if
you
died they would protect your
children because there's a good chance
you you would die in war okay you were
afraid that if I died who's going to
look after my wife and who's going to
look after my children and the way you
build Intimacy in community is by
Sleeping with each other's wife so that
you became one big
family okay does that make sense
guys any questions so
far I know this is controversial I know
this is hard to understand okay
but um with evidence that for for for
most of human history women had sexual
agency and power and sex was a way to
build community okay does it make sense
yeah
okay that's a great question okay so the
question is um is this backwards or is
it primitive okay and what I want to
show you this semester is that okay
guys there's no such concept as backward
and primitive Okay the reason why we
care about sex more than any other
people is the idea of private property
okay private
property okay so for example if I have a
wife and I do have a wife okay we have
three kids okay I want my three kids to
inherit the
money right but if my wife go sleep with
other people then who gets the private
property so in other
words we have the idea of sex as
shameful because we live in a PRI we
live in a
patriarchy okay does that make sense all
right okay sorry um let let me explain
some more later on okay all right let's
move on
all right so I want to conclude with
this
idea I want to conclude Maria gutas
argued that Old Europe was ruled by
women or women were part of the
political class and because of that
Europe at that time was more peaceful
and more stable than at any other time
in its history does that make sense so
another question then is
why would women as a political class be
uh more effective than men as a
political class okay and there are three
reasons all right the first reason
is women are more willing to cooperate
and collaborate does that make sense so
men are competitive we like status we
like power but women are much more
humble so
women are much more likely to
compromise and c and collaborate than
men are does that make sense
guys
okay so if you if men are are in control
the men want all the power but if women
are in control then women are much more
willing to share power with men does
that make sense the other thing is let's
just say like your community Gets In
conflict with another Community well
what would happen is the woman leaders
of your community would get together
with the woman leaders of that community
and you could quickly negotiate a
compromise right but men are competitive
they like status they like face so it's
much more likely that when men start to
negotiate uh it becomes violent does
that make sense okay so that's one thing
that women are better at women are
better at collaborating and compromising
that's the first thing second thing is
that women have more emotional
intelligence does that make sense guys
meaning like men care about rules right
women care more about you as a person
therefore women are much better at at
managing
people does that make sense
okay um the third thing is like men can
use violence to coorse other people
right women are not as physically strong
as men therefore they have other
strategies for controlling men and the
two main strategies are gossip okay
basically talking about you behind your
back which forces use conform but also
sex
okay so if the woman spread sex evenly
among the man the men have no reason to
fight and if someone if a man does
something bad against Community the
woman can choose to have not to not have
sex with this man okay as way to punish
him but this is all very subtle and
nonviolent me ways of forcing people to
conf to conform to the rules of the
society okay okay does that make
sense any
questions this is confusing to you guys
right okay so all so so so let's
conclude
okay before the conquest of the yayah
Old Europe was a
peaceful Ean Society okay and a lot of
the reason why is that woman were given
higher status in society so it was women
who made the rules who were the
political class in society and because
of that women are able to use um
nonviolent ways to control
Society making Society much more
peaceful and stable
okay does that make sense guys any
questions excuse
me okay okay so the question then the
question is if people are not violent
how do you control Society okay and so
um the the way you can control so
control people is by is through the idea
of
Shame okay
because everyone wants to get along
okay all right so all right here's a fun
experiment okay here's a fun experiment
what you guys can do is every time you
walk the hallways and you see
a person wearing red like like a girl
wearing red you tell her you look
fantastic okay I guarantee you within
like two weeks all the girls in the
school will be wearing
red does that make sense so you're
controlling people but you you're not
using violence you're
using the idea of Gossip shame and
flattery and that's what women do really
well do you
understand okay the the does that does
that answer your your your your
question okay any more
questions yeah so you don't have to use
violence you can you can also use
flattery okay
right any more
questions okay so um next class what
we'll do is we will look at the Y yah
people okay because the Y people are
violent they love war they're
patriarchy and um they have private
property the question then is okay how
did they come about okay what's their
origin story and why were they so so
successful in conquering all Europe okay
so that's a story we will look at next
class